the Joe Rogan experience okay here's a
better one epsteen epsteen is killer
that's one nobody thinks that that guy
hung himself
no one how about that guy so if you have
various theories or various stories that
people come out and talk about with that
one yeah and I just actually yesterday
listen to Eric when Stein's solo podcast
and Jeffrey Epstein yeah I don't know if
you listen to caught it he talks about
his kind of conspiracy view of it I wish
I was there when he met him that would
have been fascinating to see because
Eric is too smart he's almost like too
smart he's one of those guys who talked
to him like oh you poor bastard you're
burdened your burden trying to make
sense of the world around apes you know
and all the trauma of in the yet like we
were talking about he's still also the
thirteen the twenty year old kid mm-hmm
so he's seeing he had a few run-ins with
authority which makes it which makes
them suspicious of authority and I think
that our life experience defines that so
you can see Epstein in a lot of
different ways and how you've
experienced yeah for sure
like I mean but if you were there look I
okay I can tell you very nice
I can CBD kill fun yeah I like it
I know actually quite a lot of people
that have met Epstein do you really yeah
because you're in a scientific yes
especially at MIT it was a big donor
you've tainted a lot of people's
reputations yeah knowing him basically
if you took a picture with him your
reputation is tainted
yeah yeah whether you knew him or not
but I think I I do think that outside of
conspiracy theories that he was an
exceptionally charming person so he was
good you know that charming people
charming people yeah and I don't mean to
make it sound yeah I know it's positive
or negative it is what it is is the
devil it's gonna be charming so right
right and the other thing is he
genuinely showed curiosity
towards scientific ideas even out there
big scientific especially you think that
was though have you ever thought about
that do you think that it's possible
that look I mean if you just look at it
from a perspective of is the the big
theory the big theory right is that he's
some sort of a intelligence operative
right yes so he's an intelligence
operative do you don't you think it's a
part of his job to try to infiltrate
these scientific communities I mean
there must have been a directive if he
really is an intelligence operative it's
not like they're like hey go pursue your
interest do you
Haidee I hear you have a really big love
of science just feel free to do that on
the side no what what what the [ __ ] was
he doing if he's an intelligence
operative what does the intelligence
that having sex with underage girls you
can't be that well the idea of Eric that
Eric pushes forward by the way I'm
talking to him on the podcast I do
tomorrow which is like him a lot so I've
been preparing for like a three-hour
conversation with Eric Weinstein which
will kill have you met him before yeah
yeah I did I did a podcast
oh and I've met him and I hung out with
him and you and at the college that's
right that's right but it's always an
overwhelmingly intense experience
intellectually so and in a podcast form
you have to call people out in their
[ __ ] which is very hard to do with
Eric Weiss then yeah that that theory
boy I checked out 10 minutes into that
theory called AG much and I tried to go
back to it and listen to it again I'm
like wow while he was talking like okay
I'm so far behind here of what he's I'm
just gonna like try to keep up but
recognize that I'm not going to and then
go back and then listen to it again
well he hates putting stuff into words
simply yeah he's like allergic to saying
simple stuff because it's not beautiful
in woody so he always like drenches
everything in humor and wit and this
like beautiful language well he talks to
the initiated he when when he's
describing complex things he describes
him to people that understand complex
things know but it's also mean this is
the criticism I had this what I'm gonna
nail tomorrow and always tell him is he
almost
he hates explaining the basics of
something he just skips ahead right even
for the initiated it's nice to go to the
basics to explain like what are the
ground were standing on he skips right
into the depth of things which is you
know beautiful but sometimes requires
you listening again he's too smart just
hanging out with apes like me but he
Epstein he thinks that
yeah his arm but it's possible that
Epstein is sorry what was the term use
but of the intelligence community he's
an operative operative of the
intelligence community but the the
pedophile thing is a mess up on the part
of the intelligent so they didn't know
they didn't miss that ya know so well it
could you know it could also be that he
felt like he'd get me remember when this
was all started out when he started out
doing that it was all before social
media right so he probably thought that
he had this incredible amount of power
because the fact that he was connected
and by the intelligence community if he
was they probably thought he could get
away with it makes you wonder of all the
horrible things that happen in this
world before social media before the
spread of information was bomb craziness
[Applause]